[Music]
what do you think happened in pika
rivera a few days ago lady got zapped to
the two dogs yeah wait what yeah from
the lightning yeah lady was walking her
dogs her two dogs lightning struck all
that night
the two unleashers yeah so
yeah
wait yeah and the dogs were connected to
kites with keys on them oh i okay this
is pico ribera right
resurrection i pictured a chola with two
pit bulls a cholo a chola oh
chola with two pit bulls is that right
i don't think she was a troll it doesn't
show any that's [ __ ] crazy
affiliations
but yeah she was just why was she
walking dogs in the [ __ ] rain store
that's exactly you know why because this
hardly happens and she probably got
awkwardness in her hair so [ __ ]
caught that [ __ ] amanda aquinas hasn't
happened since i think 2014 or something
someone got struck with lightning that's
pretty [ __ ] rare though did she died
in she died and the dog died
at least the instant death was maybe
painless maybe hopefully or does she
even know well ryan's like it actually
took three hours for her to die well
that's the thing is because you never
know like are you dying from the shock
or are you dying from the burning that's
at what point yeah yeah but it's like
instant right
you go
and then it's like
and then the dogs go
and then it goes all the way
because it's a conductor and then they
burn and die together but they go to
heaven it is instant though yeah
because it's like when you're [ __ ]
with raiden in mortal kombat you know
like at the at the very end
can't be [ __ ] with randy ready to be
killing people see that's why i've been
telling people to get rubber leashes
because they'll stop at you yeah but
then the dog
no but the leashes are rubber so it
doesn't conduct electricity
she probably got some chain ass troll
[ __ ] chains
so when you get electrocuted your dogs
are chilling
well if it's raining you should have
wore the [ __ ] umbrella hat
oh because if you're doing are you doing
like that you weren't you have two
leashes you need an umbrella
or a rubber hat don't let this incident
sway you from the fact that during a
thunderstorm the odds are in your favor
that you're not gonna this won't happen
you can't get cocky though it's like
super like yeah it almost never happens
right almost well she was super unlucky
remember how i tested you guys and my
electricity went out yeah that [ __ ] was
sick so
yeah so so me and nina i'm taking her
she left her car in the maintenance so i
was taking her at 7 30 in the morning to
go get it so we jump in my car which is
in a uh we have an apartment building so
it's one of those shared garages and
we're right next to the high voltage
electrical room oh [ __ ] literally she
jumps in my car and we see a giant spark
come down and we hear a huge explosion
just boom like like a literally a snap
of a sound super loud she screams and
she literally goes get the [ __ ] out of
here
and then uh so we just know that there
was a giant spark from the electrical
room i started driving out
and i was like guaranteed the
electricity is going to be out i drop
her off i come back or immediately we
get a text from our building electricity
is out and it was not it didn't come
back until like 4 00 p.m we were doing
jk oh right you come back to like four
people electricity zap the building or
zap the power away i think so something
got hit really close to us and it
created a giant explosive
spark in the uh yeah
so that that footage you got was another
day no same day that footage i got i did
a slo-mo video
not the box next to us but like i was
like we were waking up to the thunder so
i went out to the balcony i was like
what the [ __ ] because the last two days
have been like 94 degrees it was wild it
was like it was the craziest thunder and
lightning oh i'm so glad i'm not in l.a
no more
so i just took a slo-mo video
and then i literally i only record like
for 30 seconds i was like let me just
see if i can get one wow just [ __ ]
hit it so i tried to screenshot every
frame that had the lightning in it and i
was like this is ridiculous
that's probably one of the best
lightning photos that i've seen from
someone i know and the windows are all
shaking and [ __ ] from the thunder yeah
my cats are mad scared dude yeah my dog
is super oh shaking
this woman though she must have been
walking in like the middle of nowhere
though
rivera is like right next to downey yeah
but like don't they usually strike
things that's like
higher maybe she was half freakishly
cool
yeah
and she's swinging her dogs around like
this oh my god damn that's crazy because
it's that split second if she would have
paused or went a little bit faster it
would have missed her right it's like
but what if the dog was taking a [ __ ]
and she was standing
oh that's what that's what it is when
like the odds are so
like in your favor but in this case
that's the exception of like the
minutest little like percentage all
right do you think she teleported into
another universe yeah she's in the
[ __ ] old west she's a highlander did
she go back in time i think the charred
body remains it makes it difficult to
accept that theory no it's just that
she's in a multiverse nowadays to be
able to travel
uh in time and in space and all that you
have to leave your physical body here
but then the the the electricity is a
portal into
when it gets
right yeah there was a guy there was a
guy running a speed test on that bolt
and went wow it's through the roof
she's uploaded into the cloud
she's in the multi-version match and
that dude
that shout out to what lightning strike
people look like benjamin franklin i
mean he survived it's actually pretty
gruesome it's gruesome dude so does it
look like a fire when they survive does
it look like a fire either way like it
could be pretty gross you wanna see it's
just a whole burn probably right well it
like burns in a crazy pattern too hey
but how come benjamin franklin came
through cool because it would never
happen there's a lie he made that [ __ ]
up because ben franklin didn't survive
that would be a key but it didn't go
through the kite string to him because
that didn't conduct robbery or kite
stream probably yeah rubber leaking did
you use a rubber leash i think i saw a
picture of a moose that got struck but
survived and it just yeah and it had
like a crazy package
huh oh yeah massive
do you remember that story of the dude
that went to half dome
he was uh he was uh climbing free
climbing like half dome and [ __ ] like
that and then like people in his camp
were like on the top of half dome when a
lightning
hit the rock and because like he was
just in some weird place where maybe it
was like uh not wet or like the the
electricity wasn't conducting he like
survived but everybody else in the camp
just fully [ __ ] in one second died oh
my god wow
it's [ __ ] crazy that is
that's crazy your time god will take you
he's like the only friend that didn't
[ __ ] buy luna whoa
that's a that's from lightning but that
person survived yeah yeah that's crazy
that is some crazy [ __ ] yeah your boy's
standing here low key if you survive and
that doesn't [ __ ] with him that's the
sickest battle scar that's left he looks
like some kind of [ __ ] marvel
superhero spines that's that's like an
origin story man posing too he's posing
that's a tattoo he's all flexing
yeah
it does look pretty badass sometimes
other times not so much i'm sad that she
died i wish she became a superhero me
too like [ __ ] cholo from pico riviera
miss lightning she was a white chick
miss line
you know what's up i'm baby shocker
baby shocker that's tight that's tight
all right i like that one better g-shock
g-shock what's crazy is that was like a
big thunderstorm for la but when i was
in houston um we were in a hotel room
and it looked like someone
borrowed a fire truck and was
specifically blasting my hotel window
with the fire hose
like it was just like
that like someone i'm like okay guy god
i got the prank but it kept going and
then it was like
this is resume and then our [ __ ] um
hotel power went out and then i texted
my friend who lives there i'm like dude
that [ __ ] was crazy huh and he goes oh
yeah that happens all the time i'm like
damn you guys still want to live here
that's crazy dude
we don't have anything but just like
earthquakes
he's like sometimes i'll find a branch
on my range rover
i'm like what the [ __ ] he's like yeah
yeah cause [ __ ] like
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] branches fall in
this house and [ __ ] just leaves it's
just regular they're just so normal
that's why houses are cheaper in other
states you just might find a branch in
the window depending on national
disasters in oklahoma and i was like
that's tight and then i was like tornado
insurance what the [ __ ] exactly on the
box
that's how i get you huh i was like no
wonder man have you ever seen a tornado
go through a neighborhood that shit's
[ __ ] things up that's that's what
also contributes to the cost of building
something new like let's say you're a
developer and you want to build in la
now you have to abide by certain
insurances there for earthquake yeah
he's got to be earthquake proof now yeah
the code is different whether you're
building somewhere else in the state
that doesn't have that then you know
that's true [ __ ] it because i thought
tornadoes only existed in simcity you
know
yeah so come on what player wanted that
to happen yeah it's like what is this
[ __ ] or all the old buildings here that
like aren't aren't [ __ ] uh built for
rain the second that kind of rains a
little bit that was like our old dojo oh
really that happened there yeah it's
just [ __ ] we don't get hella rain all
the time so you don't like really prep
for the older buildings well yeah that's
that's another thing too is like when if
something was built during a certain
time it's grandfathered in and they
don't have to change [ __ ] like i have a
studio that doesn't even have sprinklers
i was like really and they're like yeah
it was built in [ __ ] 1905 or some
[ __ ]
they don't got to like abide by it
so you don't need springs you don't need
them though
yeah it's just to jump out the window
protocol
classic keep an old school up yeah
i thought you were talking about
sprinklers for the lawn you're talking
about those [ __ ] fire sprinklers
sprinklers yeah i also thought
this you said yeah i was like that's it
because i was like why would you bring
that [ __ ] up man like i don't have a
lawn
i don't have a lawn that's my first
world complete you have to water it
yourself brown lawn i guess i'll jump
through the window
you